[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui j'ai la joie de recevoir
James Hollain qui est un auteur de roman
noir yvelinois James Olymp bonjour
bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur ce plateau de TV 78 on va
vous consacrer ce VIP vous avez
plusieurs romans noirs à votre actif
vous avez une double casquette parce que
vous êtes à la fois colonel de
gendarmerie imaginez-vous et auteur
alors on va passer vite sur le côté
colonel de gendarmerie parce que vous
êtes là en tant que taire vous êtes vous
dirigez des unités d'investigation
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire donc en fait
c'est les unités de police judiciaire de
la gendarmerie
les sections de recherche ou les
brigades des recherches c'est dans les
zones gendarmerie ce qui enquête sur les
crimes et les délits les plus importants
c'est l'équivalent de la PJ pour la
gendarmerie d'accord mais vous faites
pas doublon avec l'APJ du coup chacun de
ces zones en fait si vous voulez il y a
les zones polices et zone gendarmerie
donc par exemple dans les Yvelines vous
avez des zones gendarmerie des zones
chacun est dans chacun
travaille différemment enfin séparément
oui c'est ça séparé
alors après vous c'est le sixième roman
qui vient de sortir aux éditions caïmans
du canon
voilà une maison d'édition qui est à
Saint-Étienne vous en avez sorti un
autre qui s'appelle juste avant en 2021
qui s'appelle pleine balle voilà donc
voilà donc voilà couverture alors moi ce
qui m'intéresserait de savoir c'est
comment on devient auteur c'était une
formation littéraire que vous aviez
comment ça s'est passé ah non j'avais
une formation littéraire j'étais même
nul puisque j'ai dû avoir 5
au bacs
j'ai fait de la dissertation et je me
suis pris manger un 5 donc j'étais nul
peut-être avoir sujet ou alors sujet ou
le style était nul à l'époque enfin je
sais pas enfin mais j'ai eu 5 en
philosophie je vous rassure donc c'est
encore un voilà j'étais pas forcément
très littéraire non en fait c'est un
défi
je m'étais fixé un défi je me dis tiens
à ce que je suis capable d'écrire un
roman non on se dit ça parce qu'on aime
écrire quand même on se dit pas
simplement
oui oui ça va tiré oui oui mais je suis
pas en plus un grand lecteur et j'ai une
culture littéraire assez nulle donc mais
je sais pas pourquoi ça j'ai eu envie de
faire ça d'accord et puis j'ai écrit le
roman je l'ai proposé un éditeur ça se
passait dans la baie de Somme je me
souviens je l'ai proposé un éditeur qui
s'appelait Ravet en saut et qu'il a pris
tout de suite alors ce premier roman
s'appelait alors ça s'appelait sacré
temps de chien qui a eu un premier prix
du premier roman du premier roman de
l'association Dora sures à Lyon il a
bien marché
et puis voilà c'était l'histoire d'une
journaliste c'est assez rigolo d'un
détenu d'une journaliste et puis comme
j'ai vu que ça marchait que ça me
plaisait j'en ai fait d'autres quoi
voilà vous avez créé des nouvelles aussi
des nouvelles en parallèle ouais c'est
en parallèle c'est pas ça c'est pas
démarré par des nouvelles donc
directement le roman ah si j'avais fait
une nouvelle pour un concours la toute
première que j'avais fait c'est un
concours en Corse
j'avais aussi une nouvelle assez marrant
tout c'était un réfugié chinois qui
synthétisait avec un Corse
et il lui portait la terre sur les
épaules à l'époque encore c'est des
cultures par terrasse et les il fallait
porter la terre les orages faisaient
descendre la terre il fallait remonter
la terre et donc le chinois remontait la
terre avec le gars et sympathisait voilà
c'est le problème la première nouvelle
que j'ai faite et puis après j'en ai
fait deux ou trois comme ça d'accord
alors on parle pas de romans policier il
y a écrit polar on parle de remonoir
vous pouvez me définir un petit peu ce
genre du roman noir par rapport au roman
polo policier habituel roman noir c'est
un peu une catégorie Fourtou je dirais
mais qui subdivise en plusieurs
plusieurs
subdivisions pour la répétition mais
le roman policier on va dire que c'est
le roman et énigme Agatha Christie il y
a un meurtre qui a colonel Moutarde
c'est le Cluedo il y a le roman noir
plutôt qui a une dimension sociétale qui
va
s'intéresser à un problème un problème
sociétal un peu et puis il y a le je
dirais le thriller qui vise à faire peur
donc là c'est simple c'est comme une
sorte de film d'horreur
faut créer de la peur chez le lecteur il
y a le roman noir humoristique façon son
Antonio etc un peu moi c'est un peu en
fait j'en ai deux
en fait je me suis aperçu que je faisais
deux il y avait deux veines début je
voulais faire comme si non sinon il
faisait un truc sympa il disait il y a
les maigres c'est les romans que j'ai
créé en une semaine en si flottant et
puis il y a la les romans sérieux voilà
que que je mets du temps à les écrire
bon moi finalement c'est le début je
voulais faire ça puis ça va pas c'était
voilà c'était pas donc maintenant en
fait finalement il y a deux deux
catégories qui se dessinent il y a les
humoristiques un peu drôle comme
celui-là et puis il est plutôt sombre
pour dire qu'il y a une veine sombre et
une veine blanche un peu comme pour
comme de la BD et le précédent la pleine
balle c'était plutôt du sombre
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas trop
c'est surtout les
personne les individus et les ressorts
individuels voilà c'est l'humain en tant
qu'individu mais dans le fait que chaque
individu finalement à peu près les mêmes
ressorts les mêmes ressentiments voilà
après il y a cette façon de réagir face
aux événements auxquels les confrontés
voilà c'est ça chacun réagit
différemment mais on s'aperçoit tous
qu'on a plus ou moins
les individus exceptionnels sont pas à
100% les indices les individus pourris
sont pas pourris à 100%
psychologiques individuels m'intéressent
c'est ça qui vous soigner beaucoup aux
personnes âges les personnages les
histoires en fait tout le monde les
oublie on a écrit depuis que les gens
écrivent les histoires c'est toutes les
mêmes par contre les personnages là
on s'attache au personnage pas aux
histoires et alors du coup je veux juste
une toute petite question pleine balle
j'ai une expression ouais ça veut dire
aller vite on dit on roule plein de
balles c'est à dire qu'on roule à
tombeau ouvert
de la police non
c'est de Largo
très bien alors du coup comment vous
organiser pour pour travailler pour
écrire et à la fois
investiguer judiciairement et ben en
fait je me lève tôt j'ai une double
journée tout comme les ménagères j'ai
une double journée alors je me lève tôt
et je me lève tôt j'écris et une fois
que j'ai fini l'écriture je bosse
d'accord
et donc c'est assez rip c'est un rythme
de vie comme ça et est-ce que alors
question hyper bateau que tout le monde
a dû vous poser mais tant pis vous vous
servez de votre travail pour nourrir vos
romans alors je me sers pas des des
enquêtes dont je connaissances parce que
vous avez à faire à des faits divers
souvent j'imagine
non je m'en sers pas en revanche comme
je connais quand j'ai des personnages
qui sont des policiers je ce que je dis
peut être véridique plausible enfin pas
vérifie
je vais pas inventer des trucs
complètement fou qui n'existe pas mais
en fait
voir les policiers
[Musique]
que dans pleine balle bon un gars qui
ferait ça il serait tout de suite en
garde à vue et en prison quoi mais
bon je pousse le
je pousse le trait mais en fait c'est
sur les six romans vous en avez qu'un ou
il y a un héros qui est policier un tout
le reste vous avez une magistrates de la
Cour des comptes vous avez une avocate
un coach en séduction
et on va y venir alors moi ce qui
m'avait ce qui m'a frappé aussi c'est là
dans ce livre vous décrivez une scène de
au crématorium de d'un enterrement
indien on est d'accord avec moult
détails on a l'impression que vous
l'avez vécu ça bah non non non
je me suis intéressé à tout ce qui était
culte indien etc puis je vous êtes
renseigné
et et
un livre précédent ok j'ai vu quelqu'un
sur Internet parler de une des
recommandations comment éplucher un
hérisson
on me l'avait raconté j'avais trouvé ça
rigolo donc je l'ai mis bon enfin j'ai
jamais épluché de Hérisson
c'est que c'est bien écrit et dites-moi
alors justement on va revenir plus
précisément donc à ce moment vous pouvez
en deux trois phrases parce que là le
temps passe me décrire un peu l'histoire
bah c'est un roman qui se passe en une
journée la journée la plus longue de
l'année
une journée parce que plein de balles
s'étant une nuit on va faire une journée
de 21 juin ça se passe
j'ai pris la plus grande et puis c'est
un gars qui c'est un jeune de banlieue
de Bobigny qui son frère a été pris en
otage par des voyous il doit soit il
donne 10000 euros le soir à 22h soit le
son frère il passe et puis bon bah par
chance sa mère lui donne une lettre où
il est il est convoqué à chez une
notaire pour les obsèques d'un individu
qui se révélera de son père et là il
découvre sa famille et
les obsèques étant passé le son père
avait prévu la chose suivante soit tout
le monde s'arrange sur l'héritage d'ici
20h soit il y en a un qui hérite de tout
donc là on va voir la famille
se déchirer alors ce qui est rigolo
finalement c'est que quand vous avez
constitué cette fratrie il y a des
métiers très divers journalistes France
Culture
[Musique]
moteur régional qui ne ce n'est pas le
cas de cet éditeur puisque celui-là est
à Saint-Étienne et je m'étais pris de
j'avais mis mes romans dans des endroits
qui me plaisaient j'avais mis au Touquet
à Deauville
et puis bon à force puis c'est des
endroits que je connais
l'an j'y suis passé enfin tout ça voilà
par mon travail donc je les ai pris les
endroits voilà personne prend lent comme
enfin je peux pas porter faire un jure à
la ville de Laurent enfin les gens
préfèrent mettre leur truc Marseille
menton alors justement et pourquoi pas à
Versailles c'est pas sexy
quand je serai vieux pour l'instant j'y
suis donc comme ça je mélange tous les
jours
c'est la police voilà c'est la police
mais bon je sais pas honnêtement dans le
je sais pas je m'attends en touche mais
par défaut de savoir
présenter une autre vision
de ces bonnes villes bourgeoises et si
paisible ça serait drôle donc là vous
avez un projet de prochain roman et
ouais j'ai fait un truc un manuscrit là
qui c'est sur une histoire de sur la
trahison c'est une histoire qui prend
qui prend pour le trafic un trafic de
drogue en fait comme comme base
ça se passe dans le chez les dealers
beaucoup
et ça va se passer où alors peut-être en
Picardie je sais pas encore
je l'ai écrit mais je déteste le lieu
encore j'ai pas voilà il est déjà non il
est pas fini vous êtes en route je suis
en train de l'écrire
ça lui plaît pas le problème sera réglé
je comprends et si ça lui plaît bah je
sais pas celui qui
serait sympa de revenir ça sera pas pour
tout de suite je pense pas parce que dit
celui-là vient de sortir
en octobre l'autre était sorti il y a un
an février 2021
soutenu ah oui oui j'écris pas mal ouais
c'est bien alors ben écoutez moi je
trouve que c'est très plaisant à lire
c'est rigolo
c'est intéressant les sont particuliers
et on est pris dans content de connaître
la fin et puis je l'ai évidemment je le
dirai pas et ben écoutez à bientôt merci
à vous continuez comme ça merci
à très vite merci merci à tous de nous
avoir suivis à très bientôt
[Musique]